or Mr Speaker as Outland earlier our
priority in Sudan first and foremost was
to evacuate our diplomats and their
families which I'm very pleased we were
one of the first countries to be able to
do Mr Speaker and since yesterday we've
been conducting a large-scale evacuation
of British Nationals
we have some of the largest numbers of
British Nationals on the ground and
rightly and I'm sure the whole house
will agree with me that it is reasonable
legal and fair to prioritize those most
vulnerable families particularly those
with elderly people in them medical
conditions but also children Mr Speaker
that's what we're in the process of
doing and I pay tribute to all those who
are making it possible leader of the SMP
Mr Speaker to be clear and I think
everyone in the house is aware of this
children in Sudan are already dying now
whether it's a Tory slogan to stop the
vote sort of Labor slogan to stop small
boats we need some more Humanity in this
city rather than race to the bottom
which we see here today so can I ask the
Prime Minister now that he has confirmed
that there is no safe illegal route well
he therefore confirmed that it would be
his government's intention to detain and
Deport a child Refugee who flees Sudan
and comes to the United Kingdom
Mr Speaker in fact because of the
efforts of our a teams we've we've
invested almost 250 million pounds in
humanitarian support in Sudan over the
past five years and Mr Speaker The
Honorable judgment does it always but
actually this country has a proud record
of compassionately supporting those who
need our assistance just over the
Lillian vulnerable people to our country
including many children and it's that
compassion that we want to make sure we
continue Mr Speaker which is why it's
precisely right that we make sure that
our system is not exploited by those
coming here illegally and that's what
our bill will deliver